- [clears throat]
Welcome back to
another installment
of "The Van and Mike Show:
The Ascension."
Shall I say, maybe,
just right at this
particular moment in time,
just "The Van and Mike Show,"
'cause...well,
we are no longer affiliated
with the television program
"Key & Peele."
- Parted ways.
- We've parted ways.
It was untenable, the situation
altogether at this point.
And I feel like, you know,
factions versus factions,
internal civil wars and whatnot.
People wanted to get us
off of the show.
We showed up on set,
we started working,
nobody said anything.
What were we supposed to do?
- And when the show
goes down in flames,
they gonna try
and turn it on us.
- Pin it on us.
And the thing is,
what the worst part is,
you're gonna see them
in the midst
of their chicanery
while you watch
this video, man.
- Their Sean Connery.
- See, it's a tragedy
that that word play
is never gonna make it
on "Key & Peele."
I said "chicanery,"
and this genius nigga back here
said the "Sean Connery."
Anyway, watch this clip.
Some bullshit.
- Save her life!
- And cut, and cut.
- Um, Peter?
- Dude, Peele,
that's Rashida Jones.
- No, no,
you can't call cut, man.
- That's Rashida Jones,
though.
- Vandaveon.
- What's up?
- Get him out of here.
- Who called cut?
- I did.
- Hey, dude.
- What the fuck are you doing?
- You can't call cut.
- That's Rashida Jones,
though.
- Yeah, you can't
fucking call cut.
- You're out of here,
it's done.
- Get of the fuck--
get off the set.
- Get out.
- No, wait a second--
- You're out, you're fired,
you're off the show.
You are off the show.
Don't talk anymore.
- But what about me
getting your phone number,
though, Rashida?
- You're fired,
good-bye.
- So, basically,
the clip speak for itself.
We followed the rules.
We followed protocol.
I called cut.
I said the word on set
that people say
when you want people
to stop shooting.
You say, "Cut."
And then gave a compliment
to the female guest star
of the show.
You got Rashida Jones
in that bed,
acting her ass off.
And in that moment,
I just felt like, to me,
just we should point this out.
- Nigga punched you
in the face.
- Oh, yeah, by the way,
I'm suing them for assault,
'cause that big white dude
with the muscles and everything,
that motherfucker
punched me in the mouth.
This foundation right here.
I got a big-ass bruise
on my mouth.
- We pressing charges.
We gonna get hundreds
of thousands of dollars
on that bitch.
- Hundreds of thousands
of dollars.
- Look out,
Comedy Central.
Or you could
just produce our show.
- There's two ways
to go about it.
So, anyway, we're gonna go
on a brief hiatus
for this program.
We got to re-group,
re-think of some things,
figure out how to redo
the business model,
get some Venn diagrams
on up in here,
do some geometry.
Or at least start a podcast.
So look out
for our podcast,
'cause that's gonna be
the next thing.
- It's sad.
- It really is sad.
The whole thing's
just falling apart.
It's like we're Rome.
I'm really sorry, everybody.
We're gonna come back to you
right quick with some new stuff,
but this has been--
this has been a disappointment.